in 1854 cholera was rife in the City of
London and for people who became
infected with it the symptoms were
pretty horrible diarrhea
leading to dehydration resulting in
death and an extraordinarily high
percentage of the afflicted population
did die around 12% of those contracting
the disease a main driver of the
outbreak was the underdeveloped sewage
system throughout the city which allowed
raw sewage to mix with sources of
drinking water but all of this was
totally unknown in the 1850s since
people primarily believed in the miasma
theory of disease and that ascribes
diseases of this kind too bad air modern
germ theory which would have identified
the sources bacteria in the drinking
water hadn't yet overturned miasma
theory and this means that the terrible
disease was running unchecked through
neighborhoods including an especially
bad outbreak in the Broad Street area of
the soho district where a 127 people had
died painfully in that one year enter
the now famous John Snow
John snow is considered one of the
fathers of modern epidemiology which
studies the patterns distribution and
effects of disease he was raised in one
of the poorest neighborhoods in New York
but he'd risen up from the coal
shoveling working-class by mastering
surgery and becoming an expert in
hygiene by the 1850s he was practicing
medicine for many of the elites in
London confronted with the outbreak
he set about advancing his own favored
explanation jerem theory and he was able
to track the disease to its source which
was a single well on Broad Street used
by all the victims of the disease so how
did he do it and the answer is
unsurprisingly geography he did it
through careful and rigorous spatial
detective work using grounded
observation and the power of mapping to
figure out and to communicate what was
going on so in this lecture I'll follow
on the lessons of John Snow to
demonstrate the disease is a spatial
phenomenon using the classic case of the
Broad Street cholera outbreak of 1854
I'll introduce the concept of
spatial epidemiology and I'll then
demonstrate what the movement of
diseases including West Nile virus and
SARS tells us about these diseases but
also about our global vulnerability to
pandemics worldwide epidemics fostered
by our interconnected world finally I'll
show that while diseases are often very
global in scope
there's a terrific unevenness to their
distributions using the case of hiv/aids
I'll show that vulnerability to disease
is a product of social and economic and
political conditions so let's go back to
Broad Street now and follow in the
footsteps of John Snow how did he crack
the case new living nearby the site of
the epidemic snow first entered the
Broad Street neighborhood and took a
case history of each of the households
that had experienced cholera
he went from house to house and he asked
people who had died what people did and
what business they went about in their
lives especially water collection
examining the proximity of each of these
households he scoured the streets in the
densest areas of the cholera cases and
located that single well that all of the
cases clearly encircled and then he
performed some further examinations of
the well water and was convinced that
this was the source of the disease he
approached the authorities in the area
the board of guardians of st. James
Parish and requested they shut down the
pump and though hesitant to do so they
removed the handle after some persuasion
and cholera in the neighborhood ceased
to further press his point snow then
published a map a map of the epidemic
showing all 13 public wells in the
vicinity as well as the locations of all
the recent cholera deaths in the area
some 578 deaths in total so a big deal
and in this terrific and now very famous
map he put a small black rectangle at
the residence of each deceased victim
residences that had multiple deaths had
a big stack of these black rectangles
and the immediate pattern is
unmistakable even to the untrained eye a
real and prominent cluster of black bars
appears around that single well the one
on Broad Street you can go to that site
today and see the wellhead memorialize
there and even a greater honor in such a
city of fine drinking
the Jon Snow pub can now be found facing
the well sight this is a well known case
and it's a good one for review since it
shows a lot of the important strengths
of geographical methods first it shows
the power of fieldwork though ultimately
snow would convince the public of the
rightness of his theory through
analytical mapping his first effort
involved getting into the neighborhoods
and talking to residents in fact he
learned that several who had been spared
the disease worked in a brewery where
they could drink beer and didn't rely on
well water and only by performing this
sort of foot work what we would later
call shoe leather
epidemiology he could confirm to his
satisfaction the source of the disease
this is a central part of geographic
methods in all kinds of geography to
this day fieldwork that method was
coupled with the singularly most
powerful tool he had at his disposal a
very well-made map as we noted many many
lectures ago maps though always partial
and inevitably biased are an
extraordinarily powerful and useful tool
both for analysis and also for rhetoric
for convincing people in this case it
was the map after all that had won the
argument for snow for our purposes the
most important lessons from the cholera
case are the disease like everything
else is spatial and its spatial in very
important ways this underlines a more
general Geographic principle the where
of something how its distributed may
reveal its why in this case studying the
distribution of cholera provides good
evidence that it's a waterborne disease
as it's coming from that well but the
principle applies more generally in
biogeography the clustering of a species
may hint at its preferred habitat in
economic geography the clustering of
certain industries may suggest the
constraining logistical or
transportation limits on production
where may tell you why now this
intuitive principle underlies a lot of
forms of geographical investigation in
methodology even if it's sometimes used
in far more theoretically or
mathematically complex applications
applied to the problem of disease this
principle is called
facial epidemiology and that's the study
of the geographic distributions of
diseases and disease cases to predict
control and understand sickness and
health and this can include several
different things first simple mapping of
disease as in the case of John snows
cholera provides a pretty powerful
health tool and a good place to explore
disease this beats the heck out of
looking at data in a big table because
your eyes have the ability to pull out
subtle spatial patterns and allow you to
ask new questions now more sophisticated
approaches exist of course Geographic
correlation can be used to explore the
relationship between a specific form of
disease and the environmental
demographic or economic conditions that
prevail where you find that disease take
for example the incidence of a disease
like valley fever this is a sickness
characterized by a terrible fever and a
cough headaches often progressing to a
very serious illness and then death
especially in older people the incidence
of the disease can be mapped in
geographic areas like census blocks or
counties or other spatial units and in
each of these same spatial units you
might collect data on for example
geology now if you ran a statistical
correlation between these datasets
overlaying the incidence of valley fever
with the characteristics of the land
surface you'd be likely to see that
valley fever is prevalent mostly where
loose soil and dust prevails in outdoor
areas and this is because the disease
agent is a fungus that thrives in dry
soils which when kicked up into the air
come to reside in people's lungs causing
the disease the key point is that maps
can be used for more than just
description they can be used to test the
relationships between disease and other
attributes of places leading to an
actual explanation an explanation of
what causes the illness so mapping
disease gives us a lot of power and
explanation natural next question is
we're so good at explaining can we use
these same spatial relationships for
predicting disease the answer is yes but
it's a lot harder first it means we need
much more powerful tools we need data
collected over long periods of time
snapshots of the
of an illness at different moments which
allows us to track it as it unfolds but
to make any meaningful predictions we'd
also need to have a really strong sense
of how the disease is transmitted how it
moves over space and if it's infectious
how its transferred between hosts
consider the case of West Nile virus
West Nile is a disease that belongs to
the Slav every day family and is carried
by mosquitoes typically we find the
disease in tropical parts of the world
and it gets its name from the site where
it first was discovered in the 1930s it
was discovered in what is today Uganda
in the westernmost branch of the upper
part of the Nile River West Nile virus
the flavivirus can produce a number of
illnesses a whole range of sickness but
one of the most common forms is West
Nile fever which includes a serious
fever chills joint pain swollen lymph
nodes and flu-like symptoms people
infected with the virus can also
contract a more serious neurological
disease though the disease isn't
typically fatal deaths from West Nile
virus are possible 2012 was the
deadliest year in the history of the
disease and it killed 286 people in the
United States alone but what's most
interesting about West Nile from a
geographical point of view is that it's
really quite new to North America and
especially to the United States so by
tracking it geographically from its
arrival on us Shores to its nationwide
spread in the last few years you'll
learn a lot about how the disease works
though prediction again remains up to
now elusive goal the first case of West
Nile in North America was reported in
New York City in the late summer of 1999
and within weeks
dozens of crows a number of cormorants
some flamingos pheasants and other birds
all contracted some kind of
unidentifiable encephalitis and early
that fall human cases of an unknown
disease were also reported across New
York and in nearby parts of New Jersey
by the end of the year
the Centers for Disease Control
identified the disease as West Nile new
to the US and rarely seen outside of
Africa Australia and the Near East
though they made a noble effort to
contain the disease before the next
mosquito season the year 2000
within a whole bunch more cases of death
across cases of the disease and death
across New York New Jersey and now into
New England in 2001 cases were reported
up and down the eastern seaboard
especially in Florida the rapid
geographic diffusion of the disease has
everything to do with its etiology the
system of causes and the origins of the
disease as I've suggested from the
original cases in New York City
the main vectors for the disease its
primary carriers in other words are
birds birds with the disease bitten by
mosquitoes pass the virus to the
mosquitoes when the same infected
mosquito bites another bird the bird
catches the disease and so on as it
turns out people and other species like
horses can certainly catch the disease
and could suffer from it but for complex
reasons they can't pass it back on so a
mosquito with the disease biting you or
me may give us the disease but then
bitten by another mosquito we won't pass
that infection on back to a new host
we're basically a dead end this means
that the geography of the disease that
we see in the first few years is one
dominated by the movement of birds their
migrations and middle-distance flying
habits this accounts strongly for the
passage of the disease at first up and
down the Atlantic coast
that's birds moving around and in 2002
and 2003 the disease broke out in a
serious way west of the Appalachians and
then into the greater Midwest and
Western mountain regions and this fat
fast rate of spread has got everything
to do with the infectious nation nature
of the virus it's the ease with which it
moves between bird hosts and mosquito
vectors but also the wide-ranging flight
of birds in the year after advancing
into the late 2000s and into the current
decade we see West Nile is basically now
endemic to North America it's a disease
that moves around in its frequency and
seriousness across the map but it's a
it's a problem in the US and Canada now
forever so can we predict where we're
gonna find West Nile virus next this is
a hotly debated question in virology and
geography alike but the uneven and jumpy
nature of the disease makes it hard to
track at the national or statewide scale
it
true however that at the local scale
people are at greater risk of
contracting the disease if they're
exposed to the mosquitoes that carry the
disease it's intuitive
this means that area is near stagnant
water or warm damp undergrowth present
more of the risk some of the geographic
features may be natural like a shallow
pond or a seasonal stream bed but other
features may be entirely man-made like a
stormwater culvert or an over watered
lawn one of the mosquitoes that carries
West Nile virus has the capacity to
reproduce in a paper cup so in that way
the West Nile case shows the more
general issue about disease geography
clearly people are affected by the
disease differently based on their
location their geographic context areas
with geographies that favor mosquito
breeding present a higher disease risk
for people who live there and have a
serious impact on regional health
outcomes on the other hand people are
constantly remaking these geographies
and can actually create the very
conditions that put them at risk I'll
give you a great example
few years ago when conducting interviews
about West Nile virus researchers
working in my team spoke with a health
manager in Reno Nevada now he explained
that his job had become much much harder
since 2008 and that mosquito populations
and complaints had mushroomed since then
along with concerns about West Nile and
other mosquito-borne diseases so why why
since 2008 well we asked and as it turns
out the economic downturn in 2008
especially in the housing market led to
widespread and large-scale abandonment
of homes you following me many of these
homes as is typical in parts of the
desert West had
pools and hot tubs and these were all
abandoned by their owners and they
turned green and stagnant now
unsurprisingly a green stagnant pool or
hot tub
is a terrific place for the mosquitoes
that can carry the West Nile virus an
abandoned hot tub can host thousands and
thousands of mosquito larvae resulting
in mosquito hot spots scattered
throughout neighborhoods so complaints
from people in areas with abandoned
pools became a significant problem for
health managers in the Reid
the disease risk was a product of an
interaction an interaction between a
built environment and a previously
unpredictable economic transition again
what's the bottom line the bottom line
is that our geographic context
determines much about our life and
health risks but that context is often
the result of human activity and
modification we can basically create our
own risk so so far we've shown that
disease is by its nature a spatial
phenomenon and that spatial epidemiology
can help us track and explain diseases
we've also seen how disease vectors the
carriers the distributors of disease are
critical in defining the geographical
extent and trajectory of diseases and
the West Nile case underlines yet
another more global geographic point
here's a disease endemic to Africa that
has come to be part of the overall
disease profile of the United States how
is that possible
clearly the disease traveled like
wildfire through the domestic bird
population but how did the West Nile
virus get to North America in the first
place it's impossible to know for sure
whether a bird carried the disease into
the region by flying in or not so
globalization of Commerce an
international jet travel mean the
disease never before seen in one part of
the world can be present in a new human
population simply as a result of a
12-hour plane ride and this increases
the probability of a global pandemic
that's an epidemic spread across wide
regions or multiple continents now
pandemics aren't new of course the black
death of the 14th century killed as many
as 75 million people as it traveled from
Asia to Europe affecting a huge swath of
humanity Spanish influenza of 1918 that
was also global in scope it may have
been brought to North America by
soldiers returning from World War one in
Europe but in this day and age where
global travel and global commerce and
global connections are so much faster
and more intense than ever before the
opportunities for diseases to have
global reach are going to be greater
one of the major pandemics scares of
recent years
SARS that's severe acute rest
tory's syndrome demonstrates this SARS
is transmitted by air meaning proximity
to a sick person kind of loud exposure
to SARS and the most startling thing
about the disease and the reason it
caused worldwide panic was the speed
with which it went from a very local
outbreak to a global one the first cases
of the disease were probably a handful
of people in rural China farming
communities probably as early as 2002 by
the end there'd be more than 8,000
reported cases of the disease worldwide
and 775 deaths spread over dozens of
countries in 2003 so how did it spread
and had it spread so quickly the
detective work here is complex but the
disease probably skipped out of rural
China in 2002 an American businessman on
a flight to Singapore died of the
disease in early 2003 and the medical
staff that treated him in Hanoi caught
the disease and this set off a global
alert but by then it was too late cases
were already being reported in Toronto
and in San Francisco and in Manila and
Hong Kong with the disease bouncing
through hospitals and hotels propelled
by long-distance travel global health
authorities like the World Health
Organization responded to the disease in
a specifically spatial way releasing
travel warnings and seeking to slow the
rate of the movement of people in an
effort to slow the rate of the disease
the last reported case of the disease
was 2004 though other viruses have
circulated in the years since the bottom
line in the SARS case is the way the
global system as an integrated network
of free trade and largely unrestricted
travel is one that makes disease
geographies extremely difficult to
govern sudden emergence of MERS which is
another corona virus in the Middle East
in 2012 raised similar enormous and
immediate fears how do we spatially
contain a disease in the age of global
travel well none of this is to say that
disease risks are universally and
indiscriminately greater now for
everyone than they were in the past I
mean nothing could be further from the
truth
people in the world
living longer with better access to
health care and better health treatment
than ever before the World Health
Organization reports that global life
expectancy increased from 64 years in
just 1990 to 70 years in 2011 the world
is actually healthier than ever what it
suggests instead is that pandemics
rapidly spreading infectious diseases
are a higher risk now for all of us on
earth than they were before the days of
hub-and-spoke air travel and global
shipping and relatively poor relatively
porous national boundaries
the spaciality and the geography of the
disease is more important now than ever
before and this spaciality is especially
acute for the most vulnerable
populations on the planet
so for the very last part of this
lecture I want to reflect on this final
reality some places and populations are
more vulnerable to disease than others
really this question is merely providing
further evidence of what we've already
learned as with the rise of cholera
disease is unevenly distributed at local
regional and global scales but the
things that make some places more
susceptible to disease often have little
to do with the characteristics or
qualities of the disease itself but
instead impinge on the social economic
and political conditions through which
the disease travels no disease
demonstrates this better than hiv/aids
acquired immunodeficiency syndrome aids
as is well known is caused by the human
immunodeficiency virus HIV the disease
is transmitted through unprotected sex
used or reused hypodermic needles
contaminated blood transfusions and can
also be passed from mother to child
during pregnancy and since the disease
stormed onto the scene in the early
1980s it's estimated to have killed
around 30 million people that's a
startling figure the disease is
ubiquitous it can be found everywhere
and amongst all populations of the world
meaning that it isn't a disease of gay
people or straight people or drug users
or white people or black people as
researchers Tony Barnett and piers
Blakey who researched the geography of
AIDS in Africa once famously wrote it's
simply a disease of
people but if you glanced at a map of
the current distribution of the disease
it shows a radical unevenness
something's going on here especially in
sub-saharan Africa which has allowed the
disease to expand rapidly and unchecked
at least until recently the adult
prevalence of the disease throughout all
of sub-saharan Africa is around 5%
compared to around 1/2 percent in North
America where the epidemic remains still
very serious in southernmost Africa the
prevalence rate exceeds 20% this disease
is simply everywhere in South Africa and
Botswana impacting every part of society
and economy but why well there are a
number of reasons that these the most
impoverished nations on earth would be
the sites for the most rapid spread of
the disease
today the rates of people testing
positive for HIV based on blood test
which is called the zero prevalence rate
are highest
their highest in countries with higher
teenage birth rates higher fertility
rates and fewer women using
contraceptives as we learned in a
previous lecture these are all precisely
the parts of the world that have
experienced high levels of under
development for many of the same reasons
countries with high HIV seroprevalence
also tend to have fewer doctors and less
access to essential medications all of
these precisely characterize the
conditions of southern Africa in highly
rural populations moreover with high
levels of subsistence agriculture often
isolated from the infrastructural
investments that larger cities and
wealthier regions receive these
conditions are quite typical poor
medical facilities and limited education
exacerbate the problem along with others
including
the reuse of needles approximate drivers
of the spread of the disease are also
closely linked to the desperation and
poverty associated with under
development for example the practice of
women depending on multiple partners for
support which is common in areas of
Africa with crushing poverty tends to
accelerate the rate of infection in
populations and much of the same can be
said of Thailand a country with the
highest zero prevalence rates in
Southeast Asia where the sex trade
thrives omits poverty and extremely
limited economic
- knees especially for women where
little political will has been exerted
to empower women and let them protect
and advance themselves this problem only
becomes worse a map of high AIDS rates
in the population is a map of economic
poverty but also political vulnerability
and the widespread presence of the
disease does a lot to reinforce the
exact same problems of under development
that caused it to spread in the first
place as the work of Barnet and Blakey
demonstrated in their path breaking
study of AIDS in Africa when members of
rural households contract AIDS and die
of the disease the household economy is
usually thrown into disarray this leads
to further impoverishment and a downward
spiral in income from one generation to
the next
resulting in higher rates of
vulnerability and infection in the next
generation so poverty poverty and AIDS
have a mutually reinforcing relationship
AIDS in this sense is more than just a
global pandemic it actually has the
remarkable capacity to seek out some of
the poorest most ecologically challenged
and most politically marginalized
populations and places in the world this
is a disease in other words with a track
record of highlighting spatial injustice
so I've demonstrated here that disease
is a very spatial phenomenon I've also
shown that by mapping and analysing the
geography of disease we can learn a
great deal about the character of
disease itself as well as the social and
economic context through which disease
travels thinking about disease through
the lens of spatial epidemiology as in
the case of West Nile virus provides us
with insights into both the natural
factors that account for the spread of
the disease like bird migrations as well
as the human ones like abandoned
swimming pools I've also shown that as
in the case of SARS the circulation of
diseases is often accelerated by our
increasingly interconnected and
globalized world finally I've
demonstrated that the geography of
disease is profoundly influenced by
social economic and political
vulnerability as for the geographies of
climate and land use and agriculture
tried to show that people and society
are deeply affected by the distribution
of disease but exactly as for those
other geographies the distribution of
disease is itself the result of other
human actions and conditions hiv/aids
most notably has had a profound impact
on the economic development of some of
the regions some of the regions of the
world in the last 30 years at the same
time these economic conditions set the
stage for the persistence of the disease
the geography of disease reinforces this
fundamental lesson that people are made
by geographies
but those geographies are often made by
people and with that lesson in mind we
turn now to address the way global
forces often impact very local
environments and this insight is
referred to to by geographies as
political ecology and we turn to it next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]